les fractures territoriales on en parle
énormément dans les médias dans les
journaux le sujet est partout je pense
qu'il y a deux raisons principales qui
font qu'on parle beaucoup de fractures
territoriales la première c'est l'accès
aux services il y a des difficultés
d'accès à des services à la santé de
manière très nette à l'éducation etc qui
sont très douloureusement ressentis
parce qu'il y a eu certaines
réorganisations de services
effectivement qui ont éloigné certains
services publics et puis deuxième raison
même gérer la géographique constante
beaucoup de concitoyens on a
l'impression que ces services sont plus
difficiles accessibles parce que pour
beaucoup d'entre eux je dirais il y a
une voix d'entrée numérique qui bloque
certains de nos concitoyens et puis
cette question de la fracture c'est à la
fois des difficultés actuelles et c'est
peut-être aussi et surtout beaucoup
d'inquiétudes pour le futur parce que la
transition écologique va va rebattre les
cartes dans les territoires et dans
beaucoup de territoires il y a une
inquiétude d'être plus particulièrement
victime ou plus particulièrement malmené
par ces par ces transitions à venir
quand on parle de territoires et de
fracture on pense aussi souvent à
l'évolution de la décentralisation et
revient cette question ancienne de dire
est-ce que il y a le bon partage des
compétences entre l'État et les
collectivités locales
non certainement le partage des
compétences n'est pas optimale bien
évidemment peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on
est moins à l'aube d'un nouvel acte de
décentralisation mais peut-être à une
rupture et l'idée qu'il faut penser
différemment les relations entre effelon
territoriaux aujourd'hui avec la
transition écologique les collectivités
évidemment continueront à organiser des
services publics mais on leur demande
quelque chose de radicalement nouveau et
qui n'était pas là dans les années 1980
c'est dénoncer leur contribution aux
grandes transitions en gros leur demande
plus de dire uniquement ce qu'elles font
pour leurs habitants mais on leur
demande de plus en plus de dire ce
qu'elles font pour le climat ce qu'elles
font pour l'Europe ce qu'elles font pour
les générations futures donc aujourd'hui
peut-être pour rassurer sur ces
fractures le grand travail intellectuel
politique amener et celui d'organiser
ses contributions territoriales à
transition de manière à donner une
visibilité à chacun sur comment ça va
transformer les territoires et aussi les
rassurer sur le caractère juste de cette
répartition territoriale des
transformations à venir
effectivement on remercie Xavier
Desjardins merci et pour votre présence
à cette table ronde sur les fractures
territoriales alors métropolisation
archipelisation France périphérique les
expressions sont nombreuses pour évoquer
ces fractures territoriales qui
traversent notre pays de l'État
aménageur du 20e siècle au
revendications fortes de certaines
collectivités locales pour plus de
décentralisation les profondes mutations
urbaines et sociétales qui descend
dernières années sont venus percuter la
notion d'égalité qui passionne la France
et qui est inscrite dans notre devise
les inégalités territoriales
expliqueraient selon certains le
ressentiment d'une partie de nos
concitoyens et les mouvements de
contestation que nous avons connues ces
dernières années le concept nouveau de
classe géosociale qui est développée par
picetti et kg dans leur dernière ouvrage
une histoire du conflit politique croise
les données socio-économiques des
électeurs et leur localisation
géographique la classe géosociale et dès
lors considérée par ces comme principal
déterminant du vote et pour autant
l'Insee a ses dernières semaines rendues
publiques une étude extrêmement
intéressante sur les effets de la
redistribution élargie sur les
inégalités sociales
cette étude démontre que les transferts
sociaux et l'argile pas seulement les
minimes mais l'intégralité du service du
politique publique réduisent
spectaculairement les inégalités
savez-vous que avant transfert les
ménages les plus aisés ont un revenu 18
fois plus élevé que celui des ménages
pauvres contre 1 à 3 fois supérieur
après transfert alors que sont les
fractures territoriales abondamment
documentées par les scientifiques et
commentés par les politiques les
disparités économiques entraînent-t-elle
obligatoirement des fractures
territoriales sont-elles une réalité ou
une perception la répartition des
compétences entre l'État et les
collectivités locales est-elle en cause
un nouvel acte de décentralisation
est-il nécessaire pour réduire ses
fractures avec nous et je vous demande
de les applaudir pour évoquer ce sujet
dont on parle partout je suis heureuse
d'accueillir madame la ministre
Geneviève darrieu sec monsieur le
ministre de l'Industrie Roland Lescure
monsieur le sénateur basque looké ou
ribé etc et le docteur Anne le gagne
[Applaudissements]
merci à vous pour votre présence et
votre disponibilité
on fait la parité
monsieur le ministre les disparités
territoriales proviennent pour une
grande part de l'activité économique la
désindustrialisation des territoires
ruraux et urbains à jouer un rôle majeur
dans ces disparités observées est-ce que
l'État aujourd'hui lorsqu'il pense une
stratégie économique industrielle et on
a en particulier en tête territoire
d'industrie ce fameux dispositif est-ce
que l'État intègre encore ou de nouveau
la dimension de l'égalité territoriale
totalement et particulièrement puisque
je suis ministre de l'Industrie dans
notre politique industrielle ça a été
bien dit dans la vidéo le défi majeur du
21e siècle c'est la transition
écologique et pour nous ça doit être une
révolution industrielle dire si on veut
réconcilier économie écologique et
territoires il faut que ça passe par la
réindustrialisation à la fois qu'on
verdisse nos industries traditionnelles
qui sont présentes dans nos territoires
que ce soit en Bretagne aux Pays Basque
espagnol ou dans les Landes ou dans leur
on a évidemment
territoire qui ont été des
industrialisés depuis 25 ans qu'il faut
réindustrialiser mais à une condition
c'est qu'on puisse faire de l'industrie
verte ça fait 150 ans par exemple qu'on
fait de l'acier à partir du charbon on
sait faire de l'acier à partir
d'hydrogène pour ça faut développer
l'hydrogène et donc l'économie et
l'écologie ensemble c'est la manière de
réinvestir nos territoires je vais vous
lire je vais vous juste vous lire une
petite phrase que j'ai redécouverte dans
le train qui m'a fait plaisir ce matin
ce que nous savons faire nous devons le
faire produire à nouveau en France n'est
pas une utopie mais une nécessité ce
qu'on fait d'autres nations voisines
nous pouvons le faire
programme de François bayraud en 2012 à
l'élection présidentielle merci François
comme toujours d'avoir été
d'avoir été en avance sur son temps je
pense qu'on peut être tous très fiers
depuis 2017 d'avoir amorcé un virage qui
à nouveau ouvre des usines en France on
a ouvert ces 6 dernières années 300
usines de plus qu'on en avait fermé qui
attire des investisseurs étrangers moi
je suis pour une France ouverte sur le
monde une France conquérante qui du coup
garde ses frontières ouvertes à des
investisseurs et vous le savez en
investit beaucoup dans les technologies
demain les batteries l'hydrogène les
pompes à chaleur etc et tout ça
évidemment ça développe nos territoires
donc pour moi la réindustrialisation est
à parler de territoire d'industrie c'est
un programme extrêmement important qui
est ancré dans les territoires
qui rassemble tous les élus Région
Département Communauté de Communes
commune et vente évidemment l'État et
qui vise à réinvestir ce territoire
c'est important économiquement c'est
important socialement c'est aussi
important politiquement parce que vous
le savez tu l'as dit depuis 25 ans la
désindustrer les nations elle s'est
accompagnée d'une montée inexorable de
la colère et des extrêmes Trump a été
élu dans ce qu'on appelle la ceinture
rouillée là les trois quatre étains
industriels du nord-est des États-Unis
le brexit a été voté dans le nord de
l'Angleterre et évidemment chez nous
Marine Le Pen et son père avant elle ont
fait leur lit de la désindustrialisation
donc la réindustrialisation c'est aussi
une arme anti-colaire quand une usine
ouvre on recrée de l'espoir on crée des
emplois induits y compris dans les
services de santé donc je pense qu'on a
c'est pas une formule magique mais on a
vraiment les moyens de réinvestir nos
territoires en alignant tous les élus et
dans une logique de développement
économique
merci monsieur le ministre
madame la ministre vous qui avez
sillonné ces derniers mois ces dernières
années à la fois le pays mais également
en conserver un ancrage fort territorial
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec le
constat de Xavier Desjardins qui dit que
la difficulté d'accès au service public
est une des raisons des crises sociales
qu'on a vécu voilà pourquoi alors que
l'État français et le pays qui
consacrent la part la plus importante de
son pays B au politique de solidarité on
vit aujourd'hui une crise démocratique
et un sentiment d'injustice de nos
concitoyens est-ce que vous vous êtes
d'accord avec ça est-ce que vous avez un
mot d'analyse et quels sont selon vous
les services publics qui sont les plus
touchés par les inégalités
bien bonjour à toutes et à tous et ravi
d'être avec vous pour parler de ce sujet
de ce thème que je connais bien et qui
m'intéresse profondément
il n'y a pas que les services publics
pour moi il y a les services publics
bien sûr aujourd'hui les sujets de santé
les sujets de mobilité mais c'est pas
que ça c'est aussi un sentiment que tout
arrive tard
il y a 22 millions de Français qui sont
dans les zones rurales aujourd'hui en
France et un tiers
de nos concitoyens
et 88% de communes rurales
c'est beaucoup et bien dans ces endroits
là bien entendu la fibre Internet et B
c'est arrivé très longtemps ça arrive
encore lentement dans certaines
territoires
le téléphone la téléphonie arrive
lentement aussi
les zones blanches il y a de moins en
moins parce qu'il y a eu une action
déterminée notamment pendant ces 6
dernières années pour déployer tous ces
moyens modernes de communication mais
ils sont pas comme modernes ils sont
indispensables à l'heure actuelle
aujourd'hui on prône les véhicules
électriques
moi je trouve que c'est bien
mais allez dans les campagnes aller voir
s'il y a des bornes de recharge pour les
véhicules électriques il n'y en a pas
donc si vous voulez on a toujours eu
l'impression qu'on mettait la charrue
avant les bœufs et particulièrement dans
ses territoires le premier sujet ce sont
les tous ces réseaux c'est absolument
essentiel il y a bien sûr l'électricité
l'eau bon ça elle est partout et c'est
heureux mais les réseaux numériques les
réseaux téléphoniques et cette espèce de
de lenteur de déploiement a été vécu
aussi comme une vraie différenciation
par rapport au ce qu'on voit à la télé
quand on est à la campagne
aux émissions où on prône bah voilà les
startups la modernité etc et vous vous
êtes chez vous et vous dites mais moi
j'ai même pas internet et mes enfants
rouspètent parce que ils peuvent pas
faire comme leurs camarades donc si vous
voulez il y a aussi cette ce fait là qui
est un fait important qu'il faut prendre
en considération
et bien entendu il y a bon Roland a
parlé du déploiement industriel et je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec lui il
faut remettre de l'activité dans ces
territoires mais pas que de l'activité
de qualifications ouvriers ou travaux
manuels il faut remettre une activité
diversifiée avec tous niveaux des
ingénieurs des techniciens supérieurs
pour faire de la diversification de la
société et on a véritablement besoin de
tout cet ensemble pour arriver à à
donner le sentiment dans tous ces
territoires ruraux que en définitive ils
évoluent aussi bien et aussi vite dans
la modernité tout en restant avec leur
particularisme d'éloignement bien
souvent
mais ça qui est voilà qui est une un
fait on habite à la campagne on sait
très bien que on aura des kilomètres à
faire donc voilà je crois que tous ces
sujets là sont vraiment au cœur de
[Musique]
sentiment
négatif d'ailleurs qu'on ne s'occupe pas
de ces territoires alors qu'on n'a
jamais mis autant d'argent depuis les
six dernières années dans ces
territoires
les contrats de ruralité les petites
villes de demain les villages d'avenir
maintenant donc on a vraiment une
palette d'outils pour aider au
déploiement et au développement mais
tout ça s'est fait beaucoup plus
lentement que dans les grandes
métropoles et avec un outil universel
maintenant enfin depuis longtemps que la
télévision et qui montre ce contraste
entre les deux les deux typologies de
territoires mais bien sûr dans les
services publics qui ont disparu France
service formidable formidable dispositif
qui rendent des services énormes à nos
concitoyens les conseillers numériques
formidables qui aident les personnes à
remplir à
maîtriser l'outil numérique mais
également
un problème en santé quand même
avec une désertification médicale qui ne
touche pas que les campagnes qui
touchent aussi
les villes et certains quartiers des
villes et bien sûr la mobilité qui reste
un sujet majeur j'entendais hier dans Je
j'arrête après c'est pour vous expliquer
comment les messages peuvent être perçus
de façon de façon différente j'entendais
hier je regardais des infos une jeune
femme il parlait de transition
écologique etc dire bah moi de façon
j'ai pas de voiture et de toute façon je
me déplace qu'en vélo ou en transport en
commun et puis elle disait ça avec un
ton père en toi d'un air de dire ben
vous vous n'avez qu'à faire pareil parce
que moi je prends mes responsabilités je
lui dis n'habite pas au milieu de la
Creuse ou dans la forêt landaise parce
qu'elle pourrait pas parler comme ça
merci
alors madame la ministre vient de le
dire la santé une des préoccupations la
préoccupations numéro une des Français
aujourd'hui
docteur
la santé reste une compétence régalienne
pourtant la colère gronde dans nos
territoires et à chaque fermeture de
maternité vient le cortège des
manifestations des habitants des
soignants des élus locaux les ARS sont
souvent pointés du doigt et les élus
locaux désormais se sont emparés de ce
sujet de la santé pour pallier ce qui
apparaît aux yeux des habitants comme au
leurre une immense carence de l'État
voilà plein d'investissements
d'initiatives locales on court
actuellement
les élus des régions ont même été
jusqu'à réclamer le transfert de cette
compétence un transfert plein et entier
en matière de santé Anne la
décentralisation est-elle réellement une
garantie de l'égalité de la réduction
des inégalités de l'égalité d'accès aux
soins
merci merci Anne moi je suis très honoré
d'être avec vous cet après-midi je
rappellerai deux choses la première
chose c'est que la santé effectivement
dépend de l'état dans le Code de la
Santé de la santé publique l'État est
garant de l'organisation de la santé et
j'irai même un petit peu plus loin c'est
à dire que
on parle dans la Constitution française
qui date de 1946 dans la Linéa 11 de
l'égalité d'accès aux soins de
l'ensemble de la population et de
l'égalité de la distribution des soins
au niveau d'un au niveau d'un territoire
donc on peut aujourd'hui être
effectivement assez préoccupé
compris la Constitution quasiment
française ne soit plus respectée sur ce
sur ce sujet là pour moi il y a un avant
et un après covid le covid il a été un
point de rupture ou un point de bascule
il a été le révélateur de profonde
inégalité sociale pour les personnes
âgées les personnes en situation de
handicap les personnes souffrant de
maladies de maladies chroniques les
familles monoparentales ou les personnes
qui n'avaient pas de qui n'avaient pas
d'emploi qui ont été les premiers
percutés par la crise covid les plus
pauvres les plus fragiles c'est ceux qui
ont eu le moins de recours aux soins
pendant la pendant la crise covid les
logements ont été un sujet aussi et le
son dans le cadre de la santé c'est à
dire que lorsque vous avez un logement
plus petit et bien la promiscuité existe
et le covid a été révélateur de troubles
de santé mentaux et surtout de violences
intrafamiliales favoriser par par cette
par cette promiscuité donc pour moi le
covid il a révélé aussi
des difficultés d'agilité de la GRS je
vais parler de façon très politiquement
correcte et par contre j'ai trouvé moi
comme comme médecin la grande réactivité
des lecture aux côtés aux côtés des
professionnels de santé et comme
révélateur je préexister avant la crise
une perte de sens chez les
professionnels de santé médecins
paramètres qui vraiment a été révélé par
cette par cette crise covid et après la
crise covid on a eu un moment où
effectivement on s'est fédérés et
ensuite la crise s'éloignant un peu et
bien les difficultés les difficultés
sont réapparues et en particulier dans
les territoires les plus pauvres les
plus fragiles les plus ruraux comme
comme en parler Geneviève maintenant la
crise covid et je vais répondre
vraiment précisément à ta question ça a
été un accélérateur
au-delà des bien évidemment des
de tous les morts qu'il y a eu ça a été
un accélérateur de collaboration de
coordination sur nos territoires c'est
la première fois que la ville et
l'hôpital se sont parlé c'est la
première fois que la ville l'hôpital les
sapeurs-pompiers ont aussi bien œuvré
ensemble c'est la première fois que la
ville la plus l'hôpital et
sapeurs-pompiers et les élus ont avec
une grande réactivité avec une grande
détermination et au plus près du terrain
ont réussi à résoudre des problèmes que
deux mois avant on aurait pensé
impossible à résoudre j'en veux pour
preuve la création des sons de
vaccination ou la création des centres
de dépistage donc le révélateur le grand
révélateur pour moi de avant 2020 et
aujourd'hui c'est qu'effectivement il
s'est passé quelque chose c'est que
c'est en proximité qu'on a réussi à
répondre à des sujets de santé publique
et que maintenant c'est ce Cairo cela
c'est l'opportunité qu'il faut saisir
d'une crise c'est que désormais moi je
suis convaincu et je pense que j'espère
que la loi valve tout ira dans ce sens
là c'est qu'il faut construire les
politiques de santé à partir du
territoire dans une approche
populationnelle certes il faut que
l'État nous trace les grandes lignes
mais qu'il faut il faut que en fait les
acteurs de terrain co-construisent la
politique de santé répondant aux besoins
de la population il est évident que dans
les Landes on n'a pas les mêmes besoins
car çaelle et que à Sarcelles on n'a pas
les mêmes besoins qu'à doué et qu'à doué
on n'a pas les mêmes besoins qu'il y a
qu'un père donc ça vraiment cette
responsabilité populationnelle en
ancrant une politique co-construite avec
les acteurs de terrain et les citoyens
ça me paraît indispensable je terminerai
une dernière chose je crois profondément
que par ailleurs il faut parier sur la
démocratie en santé et sur la place des
patients partenaires des usagers parce
que
un autre révélateur de la crise covid
c'est que les grands oubliés de cette
crise ont été les personnes
âgées mais parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de
dialogue avec avec eux ou avec leur
famille au plus près des territoires
donc la question c'est que moi je crois
profondément à la construction
je mettrai un bémol pour les projets
régionaux de santé qui sont actuellement
sur la table je garderai ce que j'en
pense aujourd'hui pour moi c'est des PRS
des projets régionaux de santé qui sont
dans un continuum alors qu'il faudrait
que ce soit des projets régionaux de
santé qui soient des projets régionaux
de santé de rupture parce que la crise
est grave et qu'effectivement l'accès
aux soins la première préoccupation des
Français donc une
on peut l'appeler
aucune compétence qui doit rester
régalienne et une capacité de
différenciation avec une co-construction
de ces projets merci beaucoup monsieur
le sénateur l'organisation des
territoires en Espagne et
fondamentalement différentes voilà on
est sur un état plutôt régionalisé
existe-t-il et peut-être bien que vous
preniez le temps de nous réexpliquer ça
existe-t-il des disparités en Espagne
comme en France ou est-ce que la
régionalisation a permis de combler ou
d'exécerber ces questions et comment du
coup dans un État organisé de manière
très régionalisée cette étape peut
garantir l'égalité d'accès voilà au
service public
merci beaucoup
d’abord si vous me permettez je voudrais
remercier modem et le Parti démocratique
européenne par l'invitation que nous
avons eu pour participer dans cette
université de rentrée le programme est
véritablement formidable vous allez
aborder vous êtes en train d'aborder
tous les sujets qui intéressent les
citoyen nous sommes partis politiques
des organisations sociales et politiques
au service des citoyens et disons
l'ambiance est formidable et voilà merci
beaucoup je tenais à vous dire tout
d'abord j'ai eu l'occasion hier de dire
bonjour à Monsieur Bayrou un via amis du
Parti national basque et voilà
votre question en effet
l'État espagnol c'est un État
décentralisé de points de vie politique
d'un point de vue administratif c'est
vrai que si ce n'est que ce n'était pas
pour le Pays Basque que la Catalogne je
crois que ils ont les dessins de l'État
serait très très différente et alors il
existe des inégalités en effet des
inégalités entre personnes des
inégalités égalité économiques des
inégalités sociales et aussi des
inégalités territoriales pour nous pour
moi c'est très important et quand on
parle des inégalités ne parlez pas
seulement du revenu par tête ou du PIB
depuis des années c'est que c'est
quelque chose qui est au Pays Basque au
gouvernement basque et dans les
différents administrations basques nous
avons entre leurs mains et nous avons
disons à la tête c'est de parler
d'autres facteurs qui
disons conditions les inégalités moi je
parle de l'indice de développement
humain on parle de l'indice Jenny de
l'aéropé donc de développement humain
soutenable c'est-à-dire que on tient pas
compte seulement le revenu par terre le
PIB mais aussi toute une série de
paramètres qui concerne la santé
l'éducation l'environnement ou laisser
une phrase structure les inégalités sont
évidemment sources des tensions des
anciens politiques des tensions
démocratiques aussi pour le système
démocratique il y a une des affections
de la part de la population vers les
citoyens et bon nous ont en train de
voir partout en Europe des mouvements
d'extrême droite par exemple et donc il
y a des inégalités aussi aujourd'hui
disons dû à au développement
technologique on peut parler de
l'intelligence artificielle etc etc et
alors pour surmonter les inégalités il
faut avoir une vision intégrée intégrale
de tous ces éléments et donc avoir une
responsabilité collective et
individuelle
responsabilité collectif et individuelle
pour nous pour la partie nationale
basque pour les administrations basques
les concepts de la coalition économique
et sociale et absolument fondamental
parce que la cohésion économique et
sociale qui n'a rien à voir avec les
collectivismes
c'est un facteur essentiel de la
compétitivité d'un territoire parce que
pour nous en tant que partie politique
ou mouvement sociaux et politiques la
personne l'humanisme la personne et au
centre doit être au centre de nos
politiques publiques et sa prospérité la
prospérité citoyenne le bien-être des
citoyens ne laissaient personne derrière
et par conséquent nous devons avoir une
vision intégrale et unique de tous ces
facteurs
je suis pas à l'état à l'État espagnol
30 secondes il y a des une espèce de
classement
des différentes territoires il y a des
territoires riches
diétriches sont le pays vasque la
Navarre la Catalogne et Madrid il y a
toute une série de territoires qui sont
qualifiés comme accommoder par exemple
la lagon la Rioja la canta etc il y a
toute une série de régions Méditerranée
qui sont disons moins développés que les
deux premières
le 2 premières donc je viens de parler
et il y a d'autres régions enfin
d'autres territoires qui sont dit comme
en tant que pauvre comme l'Andalousie ou
l'estomac dur alors ça pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce que la même façon que dans une
entreprise un territoire n'arrive pas à
être compétitif ou pourquoi il y a des
territoires qui arrivent à être
compétitives
bon il y a toute une série de facteur
mais aussi c'est très important et les
dernières données nous montrent que
c'est fondamental la volonté politique
les décisions politiques et avoir une
stratégie dans son ensemble pour la
compétitivité du territoire et j'ajoute
nous depuis 30 ans nous développons une
stratégie de compétitivité du territoire
du Pays Basque et que étenant compte que
la compétitivité parfois et son concept
évoque disons incapitalisme sauvage nous
ne sommes pas là nous disons depuis 30
ans toujours enfin que nous développons
une stratégie de compétitivité en
solidarité et ça c'est très important
pour nous merci look et on peut
peut-être
on peut peut-être juste rebondir sur sur
ce sujet mais ce qu'effectivement du
coup la Communauté autonome basque fait
partie des 10 régions d'Europe voilà les
plus riches enfin voilà au sens global
du terme et vous avez développé une
politique publique qui était très
ambitieuse et qui lit développement
économique et développement social et je
peux peut-être qu'on peut revenir un
tout petit peu enfin de façon
synthétique sur ce sujet parce que vous
l'avez dit c'est on oppose pas les deux
on n'ose pas le développement économique
et le développement social mais quels
ont été les ingrédients de réussite
sachant que la Communauté autonome
basque est très reconnue aujourd'hui
pour ces innovations sociales pour ces
innovations de en termes de démocratie
de stratégie énergies climat voilà vous
avez une longueur d'avance sur tout le
monde et je pense que c'est un exemple
intéressant qui peut-être inspirera
ensuite une réaction de Roland Lescure
oui là je voudrais dire aussi je crois
que le monsieur le ministre je crois
qu'il a très bien expliqué pour nous
l'industrie le secteur industriel fait
partie des ADN de notre organisation
économique et sociale nous ne parlons
pas aux Pays Basque de règne de ce
réalisation puisque nous sommes déjà
industrialisés depuis longtemps et donc
nous parlons de maintenir l'industrie en
tant que secteur moteur de notre
bien-être économique et social
évidemment depuis 20-30 ans il y a eu
une tertiérisation de l'économie
européenne des économies occidentaux
mais disons nous avions comme objectif
avoir
le secteur industriel 25% de notre PIB
on est là
on doit ajouter monsieur le ministre je
sais pas si vous êtes d'accord et toute
une série de services avancés
pour l'industrie et ça nous met dans un
qui sont au niveau de 40 % que nous
considérons 40% de notre économie est
indispralisée et aussi les 25% de
l'emploi ça doit être un emploi
industriel alors quels sont les
tout d'abord tout une série de valeur
Valère propre d'un parti comme le Parti
national basque qui est une partie de
Racine socioprétienne une partie de
centre et on parle de humanisme on parle
de dignité de personnes mettre comme je
disais avant les personnes au centre de
notre traction politique on parle de
justice sociale et moi je rappelle
toujours que le concept de la justice
sociale a été visant développé pour la
première fois en 1843 par les jésuites
d'appareil
et j'ajoute
enfin mes amis socialistes voire même
communiste donc cinq ans avant que Mars
Engels ont publié leur Manifeste
communiste
maintenant je dis parce que parfois on
dit que le Parti national va ce qui
était parti de droite non nous sommes
partis de centre économie sociale des
marchés ce qui fait la différenciation
entre ce capitalisme sauvage moi je
tiens au modèle européen de
développement économique social pas
celui pour être très clair celui des
États-Unis et on parle des égalité des
chances et pour l'égalité des chances
pour les citoyens pour les personnes
disons les administrations et c'est un
rôle très important qui doit jouer un
rôle qui ne se limite pas à disons
écoute externe du système productif
c'est-à-dire l'environnement le
s'infrastructures etc mais non disons
doit développer comme je disais avant un
rôle proactif
pour avoir pour développer les avantages
compétitifs du d'un territoire et doit
tenir compte comme je dis tout
l'ensemble des éléments qui font qu'un
territoire soit compétitif en solidarité
c'est-à-dire pas seulement le PIB le
revenu par terre mais aussi la santé
aussi le service sociaux l'environnement
et l'éducation alors quelque chose qui a
évoqué le ministre que nous développons
depuis toujours une collaboration
publique privée c'est à dire une
administration qui soit proactive
pas une administration qui soit comme je
disais avant tout simplement bon je fais
des routes non et disons une
collaboration très étroite entre les
administrations avec la entre
l'administration et le secteur productif
les entreprises pour développer cette
stratégie une collaboration le ministre
l'évoquait aussi a publique
c'est à dire entre tous les
administrations publiques voilà c'est ça
et nous nous sommes très un petit pays
le Pays Basque mais nous ont un pays
très décentralisé dont nous avons des
administrations territoriales et bien
évidemment et les mairies et
disons il faut avoir et disons volonté
politique une vision une stratégie avec
une mission qui soit maintenue dans le
temps et aussi c'est très important
avoir des compétences avoir un
financement et nous dans notre cas nous
avons un système fiscal disons
particulières des points de vie
historiques voilà c'est
disons on l'explique et on l'explique
comme ça et voilà l'industrie le maître
au centre de notre stratégie
diversification etc et nous avons fait
je finis m'intéresse je vous aviez dit
que je commence à parler je n'arrête pas
je demande je demande
mais ce que nous avons fait il est à 30
ans c'est quand un ministre et
socialiste espagnol disait que la
meilleure politique industrielle est
celle qui n'existait pas et qui s'est
plongé sur l'économie financière non
nous ont dit non nous ont révélés et
nous allons nous avons dit non nous
allons développer notre propre politique
industrielle notre propre politique
de compétitivité en solidarité en
partant des secteurs la sidérurgie etc
qui était puissant mais il faut les
moderniser diversification
internationalisation et donc ce que nous
avons fait c'est de
contracter afin de compter avec le
professeur Michael Porter qui à l'époque
n'avait pas encore publié son ouvrage
Les avantages compétitifs des nations
et disons nous avons donc travaillé
ensemble et les Pays Basque sainte les
premières cas au monde c'est une
référence mondiale qui étudie
le premier cas où ils ont les théories
de développement compétitif de Monsieur
porter ce sont appliqués au Pays Basque
c'est un cas de succès sachant toujours
que nous avons des défis et que disons
ce sont des combats la question
économique et sociale c'est un combat
toujours inachevé
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre du coup est-ce que
ce modèle de la Communauté autonome
basque vous inspire faut-il aller aussi
loin dans la décentralisation est-ce que
le mot c'est un modèle qui peut
s'appliquer en France peut-être qu'il
existe une exception française aussi et
du coup est-ce que vous reliez aussi le
développement social et même la vitalité
démocratique au succès du développement
économique évidemment enfin le cas a
tout dit bravo en passant dans un très
bon français ton français est bien
meilleur que mon masque et mon espagnol
donc vraiment bravo
non mais
l'industrie au Pays Basque il l'a dit
25%. industrie en France il y a 25 ans
25% industrie en France aujourd'hui 12%.
sa dit presque tout et je veux pas dire
que l'industrie et la réponse à tout
mais évidemment c'est le cœur battant
qui emporte tout le reste il y a une
excellente note du Haut Commissariat aux
plantes que je vous engage à lire sur le
lien entre industrie et commerce
extérieur on a un déficit extérieur
abyssal en France pourquoi les seuls
filières qui sont gagnantes dans le
monde sont des filières d'excellence
l'aéronautique le luxe le 20 la santé et
donc on a besoin de reprendre la main
sur cette industrie de manière à
retrouver une capacité d'entraînement
sur tout le reste et de se remettre en
mode Conquête du monde
le cas disait j'ai un ministre espagnol
qui me disait la politique industrielle
c'est celle qui n'est pas moi je me
souviens que j'ai travaillé au ministère
des Finances dans les années 90 on a
fait des choses fantastiques la monnaie
unique le marché unique et évidemment
MoDem a fait partie à l'époque vous
appeliez autrement mais quand même des
grands moteurs derrière cette
construction d'un marché unique fort et
d'une monnaie unique européenne mais du
coup à l'époque la politique
industrielle était totalement disparue
on disait la seule politique
industrielle qui va c'est la politique
commerciale et la politique de la
Monique on est en train de retrouver ça
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire d'un
point de vue de du partage des tâches et
des pouvoirs entre le centre et les
ailes si je puis dire mais au fond sans
doute un peu comme tu le disais sur la
santé il faut qu'on ait des grands
principes communs il faut qu'on ait des
objectifs communs il faut qu'on ait
quelques stratégies prioritaires
communes vous avez sans doute entendu
parler de France 2030 on s'est donné une
dizaine de grands axes l'électronique et
la robotique la transition écologique
les fonds marins le spatial etc et là on
s'est dit la nation va mettre le paquet
mais ensuite ces projets d'innovation
qui vont nous permettre de réinventer
l'industrie de demain évidemment c'est
dans les territoires qui sont présents
c'est pas le ministre de l'Industrie à
Bercy qui soutien j'ai envie de faire
des batteries à Dunkerque ou de
l'électronique dans le Maine-et-Loire ce
sont les industriels ce sont les
entrepreneurs qui s'appuient beaucoup
sur les autorités locales les
communautés de communes les intercos les
régions évidemment qui ont une
responsabilité importante là-dedans
alors ça veut pas dire que les temps ne
fait rien l'état je voudrais saluer
alors je sais pas si elle est là elle
était là tout à l'heure Anne-Laure
Babeau et Bruno milliennes qui sont deux
députés exceptionnels on vient de voter
un projet de loi industrielle au Sénat à
l'Assemblée commission mixparitaire la
semaine prochaine je pense que tout ça
va être adopté définitivement dans 15
jours qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans ce
projet de loi on simplifie la vie des
autorités locales pour accélérer les
autorisations et on simplifie aussi la
vie des industriels qui veulent
s'installer dans les territoires tout en
préservant évidemment l'excellence
environnementale et c'est un peu ce que
ce que Lucas disait il y a une seconde
c'est à dire que
si on est prêt si on a une
administration des dreals des préfets
qui sont là pour appuyer le
développement économique plutôt que pour
le retenir et qu'on est dans une logique
de donnant-donnant entre le secteur
privé le secteur public un on va créer
de la prospérité et la meilleure manière
de distribuer des revenus c'est quand
même d'en créer et donc on va pouvoir
ensuite par faire notre modèle social
réinstaller des médecins dans les
territoires des écoles on a l'habitude
de dire qu'un emploi industriel c'est 3
ou 4 emploie induits mais les millions
d'empoings industriels qu'on a perdu
évidemment eux aussi se sont traduits
par des emplois et je finis sur un point
très important que que tu as mentionné
dans ton introduction
on peut être extrêmement fier d'avoir le
modèle redistributif le plus
redistributif au monde tu disais on
passe de 1 à 18 les 10% les plus riches
les 10% les plus pauvres s'il y avait
pas le modèle social 1 18 une fois qu'on
compte tout les impôts les cotisations
sociales la santé gratuite l'École etc
on passe de 1 à 3 qui est un des plus
faibles dans les pays
occidentaux
ce qu'il faut assurer maintenant c'est
préserver ce modèle social et donc faut
continuer à créer de la prospérité et il
se faut surtout y intégrer cette
dimension territoriale que vous
mentionnez tout et tous parce que on
n'est pas tout à fait égaux face à ce
modèle de redistribution et notamment
sur tout ce qui est non financier là
encore la santé l'école l'hôpital et
maternité etc et donc il faut vraiment
qu'on mette le paquet là dessus et moi
je peux vous dire que tous les jours
au ministère de l'Industrie on se pose
cette question qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire de mieux et notamment pour les
territoires qui ont souffert et qu'on
doit pouvoir redynamiser je le répète
pour des raisons économiques sociales
environnementales mais aussi avant tout
pour des raisons de cohésion de la
nation moi j'appelle mais vraiment de
tout cœur
la recréation d'une grande nation
industrielle et sociale et franchement
depuis six ans on a commencé à le faire
donc maintenant il suffit d'accélérer et
de continuer et de s'inspirer des
meilleurs merci
[Applaudissements]
puisqu'on est à peu dans les temps je
propose qu'on prenne une question de nos
auditeurs et on les remercie bien sûr
d'être très attentif et donc l'Hélios du
bras poser la question concernant la
transition écologique comment réussir à
étendre les mobilités douces au sein de
la France de la voiture notamment en
réalité je vous propose à ce sujet de
regarder cette capsule vidéo de notre
jeune démocrate président de l'Essonne
d'ailleurs Benoît Frimont Richard
président de la fédération jidem de
l'Essonne qui était qui est pharmacien
désormais et qui qui est délégué
conseiller municipal délégué ou mobilité
douce on écoute Benoît
bonjour je suis Benoît frimond Richard
je suis pharmacien dans l'Essonne et
conseiller municipal en charge des
mobilités douces à la commune d'egli et
par ailleurs membres des fédérations des
mobilités douces et cyclistes de
l'Essonne on le constate aujourd'hui
dans nos vies communes et dans nos
villes les mobilité douce augmentent de
manière très importante dans la part
modale des transports en effet sur
certains axes de grandes communes on
peut constater une augmentation de plus
100% de cycliste notamment sur le pontet
par exemple à Paris la problématique
c'est que cette augmentation des
mobilité douce a lieu sur tout le
territoire mais pas au même rythme en
effet sur les territoires périurbains et
ruraux on a une augmentation qui est
beaucoup plus modeste pourtant ces
territoires ruraux et perurbains sont
riches de potentialité par exemple en
Île-de-France 95% des individus vivent à
moins de 3 km d'une gare sur tout le
territoire national c'est 70% des
Français qui vivent à moins 6 km d'une
gare la majorité des personnes même en
territoire rural sont à moins de 10 km
de leur lieu de travail on constate donc
le vélo est par extension l'intégralité
des mobilités douces peuvent constituer
une solution parmi tant d'autres pour
participer à la démarche de transition
énergétique de notre pays les in entre
les territoires s'explique avant tout
par le manque d'infrastructures en effet
on peut le constater aujourd'hui la
moyenne le plus sûr pour aller d'un
village à un autre et l'automobile et
exclusivement l'automobile à titre
personnel et dans la commune je suis en
train actuellement de monter une piste
cyclable sur l'un des axes principaux de
la commune elle est financée à la fois
par la Région Île de France et par les
intercommunalités on peut se poser la
question de est-ce que le vélo à la
capacité ou pas de remplacer la voiture
on peut prendre par exemple l'exemple de
l'Allemagne qui a un bon relief on est
environ à 10% de moyenne nationale
aujourd'hui de par modèle du vélo ce qui
est intéressant mais pas suffisant même
pour la transition énergétique si par
hasard nous mettons tous les moyens par
rapport à cela on peut espérer viser
1,30%. mais ça ça va nécessitera
d'importance aménagements à la fois
d'abord et avant tout sur les
infrastructures et ensuite il y a un
changement de culture il est temps
aujourd'hui d'aller plus loin et je
souhaite un bon débat aux personnes qui
vont réfléchir à ça aujourd'hui
merci à Benoît alors Geneviève je te
voyais réagir est-ce que voilà qu'est-ce
que tu peux nous dire par rapport à ce
témoignage bien sûr et est-ce que le
climat le changement climatique ces
questions climatiques est-ce que c'est
finalement facteur de solidarité ou
facteur de d'accroissement des fractures
ça c'est une bonne question
pour les mobilités douces et je vois la
question là je vais parler de ça d'abord
c'est un peu la même chose que quand je
parlais des réseaux c'est à dire sont
des choses qui arrivent à la campagne
mais après voilà dans un deuxième temps
néanmoins il y a des départements très
dynamiques moi je suis dans un
département assez dynamique c'est vrai
que le Conseil départemental je vois
toujours un odeur de sainteté avec eux
mais je dois ils ont un plan vélo qui
était particulièrement intéressant avec
une dynamique de de financement et de
construction de pistes cyclables qui
sont qui sont vraiment sont des des
beaux des belles infrastructures et
après il faut que chaque
intercommunalité travaille sur un plan
vélo parce que c'est vrai que
tout le monde ne fait pas 50 km matin et
soir pour aller travailler au milieu de
la forêt des pins certains c'est 5 km 3
km 10 km
bon après ça ne coûte et puis je crois
que ce sont des choses qu'il faut
programmer il faut en avoir la volonté
politique d'abord et ensuite il faut le
programmer et troisièmement c'est un
changement d'habitude réel et important
pour les habitants prendre un vélo au
lieu de prendre une voiture c'est pas
pareil ça va moins vite ça demande un
effort physique mais ça c'est bien en
médecins que je suis je peux dire que je
trouve que c'est bon pour la santé quand
même et
bon voilà c'est c'est une temporalité
qui est qui est différente et je crois
que ça doit rentrer surtout maintenant
dans une éducation de nos jeunes et de
nos enfants et leur donner l'habitude de
prendre un vélo pour se déplacer mais il
faut avoir des infrastructures
sécurisées bien entendu c'est ça qui est
important donc voilà c'est pas
impossible en ruralité au contraire et
ça peut ça peut se ça peut se faire
et la deuxième question qui concernait
changement climatique est-ce que
changement de solidarité ou un
démultiplicateur de fractures
territoriale
bon le changement climatique il entraîne
une réelle
inquiétude déjà
voyez le sujet de l'eau
j'ai fait une campagne régionale dans ma
belle région nouvelle-aquitaine en 2021
je ne porte jamais porté ce sujet en
priorité je peux vous dire que ça
l'intéressait personne
ça l'intéressait personne déjà la
campagne régionale n'a intéressé
personne on sortait on était encore
confiné alors vous voyez vous imaginez
que les gens avaient la tête ailleurs
mais ce sujet de l'eau n'intéressait
personne bien entendu que c'était pas
sorti de ma tête par un truchement
extraordinaire c'est
sur les 20 dernières années on voit bien
les difficultés d'irrigation pour les
agriculteurs et je suis dans un
département très agricole on voit bien
les difficultés d'approvisionnement
d'eau puisque on a des départements où
il n'y a pas d'eau potable l'été pour
les habitants la Corrèze par exemple on
disait que c'était que ce que cette
région du Massif central était
le réservoir de la France réservoir rien
du tout
aujourd'hui donc il y a vraiment des
sujets qui peuvent créer des véritables
fractures territoriales si on ne
travaille pas mais d'arrache-pied sur
dans ces domaines-là c'est toujours des
histoires de réseaux je
l'ai dit en préambule on a le sentiment
que c'est une question annexe c'est une
question centrale et je crois que l'on a
vraiment besoin de de travailler sur ces
sujets avec beaucoup parce que sans eau
les plantes ne poussent pas mais
l'humain ne vit pas non plus donc on a
vraiment un sujet qui est un sujet
majeur qui peut être un sujet de
fracture dans nos territoires
non mais deux mots là-dessus d'abord un
moi j'adore le vélo
on a un ministre des Transports qui
adorent le vélo et encore plus important
on a une première ministre dans le vélo
et qui a été ministre des Transports
donc elle avait fait adopter un plan
vélo tu t'en souviens Geneviève ce que
tu es au gouvernement à l'époque et
évidemment en tant que première ministre
elle l'a prolongé et amplifié donc je
suis un peu déçu que l'État est pas
contribué à la piste cyclable qui nous a
été décrit tout à l'heure j'ai entendu
communauté de communes et région parce
que il y a des sous il y a deux
milliards il y a 2 milliards pour
développer les infrastructures donc
saisissez en vous parce que vraiment on
pousse beaucoup pour le développement du
vélo c'est pas la réponse à tout tu l'as
dit quand on fait 50 km c'est plus
compliqué qu'on en fait 10 mais c'est
quand même une des réponses j'imagine
que le docteur qui est à ma gauche ne me
démentira pas c'est aussi très bon pour
la santé
je rajoute une petite touche quand même
moi quand j'étais gamin on avait tous
les deux trois ans à Noël un vélo
c'était le cadeau de Noël et à l'époque
c'était Peugeot ou Motobécane tous Voilà
je vois qu'on a
et merci c'est vrai donc il y avait il y
avait des vélos fabriqués en France et
donc pour moi le défi du développement
du vélo il doit aussi s'accompagner vous
allez croire que je suis monomaniak mais
je suis ministre de l'Industrie donc du
développement d'une filière industrielle
en France et aujourd'hui il y a des
entreprises qui s'intéressent à ça il y
a des entreprises qui développent des
vélos fabriqués en France assemblés en
France il faut qu'on fabrique un million
de vélo en France pour l'instant en
assemble deux à trois cent mille et
c'est un des défis du ministre de
l'Industrie donc voilà c'est une réponse
là encore aux enjeux de changement
climatique aux enjeux de mobilité mais
aussi aux enjeux industriels alors
est-ce que le changement climatique est
égalitaire ou inégalitaire si on fait
rien il va être inégalitaire par
construction il va être vis-à-vis des
territoires il va aussi être
inégalitaire socialement parce que
celles et ceux qui vont payer le plus
pour isoler leur logement pour acheter
une pompe à chaleur qui est évidemment
bien plus efficace mais qui coûte 10.000
euros de plus bah c'est ceux qui peuvent
le moins se l'offrir et c'est pour ça
que la politique publique doit être
extrêmement active là-dessus alors on
l'aime à prime rénove on subventionne
les véhicules électriques et à partir de
l'année prochaine j'en suis extrêmement
heureux on va subventionner les
véhicules électriques faits en Europe et
puis ceux qui sont faits au bout du
monde donc la politique politique la
politique publique peut travailler à ça
pour s'assurer que la transition
écologique est soit juste mais là encore
vraiment je répète une dernière fois
mais la meilleure manière de réconcilier
économie écologique c'est de développer
l'industrie chez nous dire que l'exemple
typique du véhicule électrique
si on veut rouler propre
on vend des véhicules électriques
partout mais si on veut voler rouler
propre pardon et en plus créer de
l'emploi de la prospérité il faut rouler
propre français alors oui Geneviève la
dire l'introduction ça me permettra de
boucler la boucle faut aussi des pompes
et des bornes électriques partout pour
l'instant il y en a 100 000 on a un plan
pour en développer jusqu'à un million
dans les 50 qui viennent donc on va en
avoir mais une fois qu'on aura les
bonnes électriques fabriqués en France
partout il faut aussi qu'on puisse
acheter des véhicules électriques faire
en France avec des batteries électriques
fait en France avec du lithium extrait
de mine française bref c'est toute une
filière qu'on est en train de repenser
et de réinstaller chez nous je parlais
en introduction de révolution
industrielle c'est vraiment ce qu'on est
en train de vivre aujourd'hui il faut
que cette révolution industrielle ce
soit une révolution industrielle
française et européenne comme on l'a
fait il y a 50 ans et comme on l'a
oublié un peu trop ces vins 25 dernières
années
alors une réaction très courte d'âne et
ensuite on prendra une question de la
salle une réaction très courte sur la
partie des transitions de la transition
écologique aujourd'hui la définition
même de la santé elle a évolué avant on
parlait de la définition de l'OMS d'un
bien-être physique psychique
psychosocial voilà aujourd'hui on parle
de santé animale humaine et
environnementale et des déterminants de
santé que sont l'eau l'air les mobilités
l'alimentation le niveau d'éducation
donc effectivement tout ça est dans un
cercle dans un cercle vertueux qu'on
doit co-construire ensemble je le redis
au plus près du terrain en étant
vigilant je l'ai pas dit tout à l'heure
je me permets quand même de le dire
à une instrumentalisation mais en tout
cas moi je suis très prudente je vais
mettre les pieds dans le plat de confier
la santé uniquement à des élus aux
mairies ou aux agglomérations je pense
qu'il faut faire très attention à des
risques quand tous les cas de
clientélisme ou
industrialisation c'est ce que je vous
l'ai dit et puis j'ai un masque à mes à
mes côtés donc je suis très heureuse
étant bretonne de voir qu'effectivement
le l'autonomie basque peut fonctionner
et peut être et peut être vertueuse
quant un dernier mot sur la transition
écologique oui ça va avoir des
répercussions Geneviève Lady sur l'eau
ça va avoir les répercussions sur la
qualité de l'air ça avoir des
répercussions sur l'organisation de
notre système de santé sur les flux
migratoires y compris à l'intérieur de
notre pays avec des gens qui vont venir
vivre en Bretagne parce qu'il fait bon
vivre parce qu'il fait frais et donc il
va falloir effectivement Geneviève parlé
de d'anti d'anticiper les choses je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que
je suis préoccupé on anticipe pas
suffisamment les choses par rapport à
toutes ces transitions que l'on vit on
n'a pas du tout abordé l'intelligence
artificielle qui va aussi révolutionner
nos territoires et leur organisation et
les métiers et
on sera invité ce soir pour pour en
parler mais voilà merci merci en tous
les cas
merci Anne
juste je me permets juste une chose
et c'est pas élégant mais quand on parle
de mobilité douce et que on n'a pas des
lots logements qui sont accessibles aux
aides-soignantes aux infirmières à moins
de 40 ou 50 km on peut imaginer toutes
les mobilités tous de la terre mais
c'est le logement aussi sur lequel il va
falloir avoir une action forte et rapide
énorme enjeu pour les années à venir
c'est vrai alors une question de la
salle Monique
bonjour à tous Je me présente Monique
c'est ma voix je suis maire d'un village
dans l'agglomération de Pau Mazères
lezons et je suis première
vice-présidente de la communauté
d'agglomération de Pau Béarn Pyrénées
présidée par François Bayrou et comme il
n'est pas là je pense que s'il était là
il vous aurait parlé d'un problème que
nous avons en Béarn monsieur le ministre
vous avez dressé un paysage parfait de
tout ce dont nous avons besoin en France
pour la réindustrialisation très bien je
veux vous parler un petit peu du Béarn
nous avons en Béarn et en Pays Basque
français c'est à dire dans les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques nous avons la
chance d'avoir vraiment des industries
flow ils sentent nous avons un taux de
chômage très bas et c'est un département
qui se porte très très bien sur le plan
économique cependant nous sommes
extrêmement inquiets parce que nous
vivons depuis quelques années et tout
particulièrement depuis le début de du
covid
nous avons un gros problème de
puisque nous avons perdu énormément de
liaisons aériennes entre Pau et Paris
nous n'avons plus que un vol par jour
pour aller à Orly aujourd'hui
et 4 pour aller à
Roissy mais tout le monde ne part pas à
l'étranger n'est-ce pas et nous avons de
gros gros problèmes de rails et donc de
desserts ferroviaire François Bayrou a
parlé pas plus tard que ce lundi au
président pharaon doux président de la
SNCF pour s'agissant du rail mais Air
France nous laisse tomber lamentablement
alors que c'est une entreprise française
qui a été très très largement dotée par
des fonds publics de verser par l'État
je ne sais plus combien de millions de
milliards pardon voilà donc c'est
vraiment scandaleux nous avons donc un
énorme problème d'aménagement du
territoire et de
désenclavement c'est ce dont je voulais
vous parler monsieur le min parce qu'il
est important aussi de travailler avec
votre homologue des transports on a
parlé des voies douces moi aussi j'adore
le vélo mais enfin si on ne peut pas
aller à Paris plusieurs fois par jour
nous avons tous les jours des élus de ma
communauté d'agglo qui sont là aussi
tous les jours nous avons des
industriels qui nous parlent et qui nous
disent attention
ceci est un poison long et nos
industries pourraient se recentraliser
sur Paris les sièges sociaux n'ont pas
envie de se déplacer forcément en Béarn
à ce prix là quoi c'est à dire c'est
l'horreur pour faire les déplacements
d'ailleurs demander aux députés
sénateurs qui doivent aller travailler à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est un vrai
calvaire voilà pardon c'est un peu long
mais je veux décrire un petit peu le
tableau et c'est vraiment très
inquiétant nous avons par exemple une
industrie aéronautique magnifique nous
avons tout près de Pau l'usine safran
qui fabrique un sur deux des moteurs
d'hélicoptère qui volent dans le monde
comme le dit souvent François Bayrou
nous avons également le siège
scientifique de Total énergie qui est
sur peau nous avons de l'agroalimentaire
rallye etc bon enfin je vais m'arrêtais
là mais nous sommes très très inquiets
donc il faut absolument monsieur le
ministre où je vous en supplie que vous
travaillez aussi avec le ministère des
Transports pour nous
désenclaver parce que là ça y est ça a
déjà commencé et ce serait quand même
très très dommage parce que vous avez
derrière vu une vue magnifique de la
ville de Pau
enlevez-moi ces questions là bas ça
commence au château d'Henri IV à gauche
le boulevard des Pyrénées qui traversent
tout le tous les tous la comment on
appelle ça l'estrade et on finit là à la
place Royale et la mairie de Pau et on
aperçoit même le bureau de François
bayroula
Bon monsieur le ministre alors c'est
tellement beau que ça serait dommage que
tout ça périclite parce qu'on est
enclavé comme des ploucs perdus au fin
fond bas à gauche alors quand la fête
merci la question c'est en fait comment
on bosse en interministérialidité et
comment est-ce qu'on fait système en
fait voilà non mais vous parlez à un
ministre qui a passé 4h30 coincé dans un
train en train de s'y éparis le 28 août
parce que le train était tombé en panne
sèche donc
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il y
avait pas seulement le ministre il y
avait aussi tous les journalistes
politiques qui avaient suivi Bruno Le
Maire pour sa rentrée et une équipe de
BFM donc ça a été la panne la plus
médiatisée et le nombre de messages que
j'ai reçu de gens qui m'ont dit moi
c'est tous les jours moi c'est toutes
les semaines y compris des
parlementaires donc évidemment on doit
réinvestir dans notre transport public à
Pau et ailleurs pas seulement parce
qu'il faut que comme on dit les ploucs
de peau mais il y a pas de plouc à Pau
ça c'est c'est
voilà donc mais surtout effectivement
pour pouvoir continuer à développer ces
belles industries que vous avez à peau
il y en a d'autres avec des projets
d'avenir dont je suis très conscient qui
vont se développer donc oui il faut
faire l'interministériel oui il faut
réinvestir dans les services publics et
vous savez quand même qu'on s'est engagé
à développer à la fois des RER
métropolitains et un certain nombre de
liaisons longue distance et oui il faut
qu'on travaille avec Air France pour
augmenter les cadences mais
on a quand je disais tout à l'heure
pendant 25 ans des industrialisés la
plupart de ces lignes n'étaient plus
rentable et donc plus là encore on crée
de l'activité à Clermont-Ferrand il y a
un certain nombre d'entreprises
emblématiques qu'on connaît bien si elle
disparaissent de Clermont-Ferrand il y a
plus d'aérodrome il y a plus de liaison
aérienne
puis il y a plus de d'avions d'affaires
non plus et donc on a plus aujourd'hui
d'aérodrome a clairement donc oui il
faut développer tout ça mais ça part de
l'industrie ça part de l'activité
économique à nous ensuite de travailler
avec Clément Maud de mon collègue pour
nous assurer que je dirais l'intendance
suis mais le point de départ de tout ça
vraiment c'est notre stratégie je sais
que François beroux et les élus de la
région ils sont extrêmement sensibles
pour cette région développons les
industries d'avenir de l'hydrogène de la
capture de carbone tout ça c'est ça
existe et ça va exister dans votre
région de manière à ce qu'on puisse
entraîner tout le reste les services
publics les transports les écoles et
toutes les mobilités pas seulement les
douces merci beaucoup
monsieur votre présence
[Applaudissements]